die agrardieselbeihilfe ist eine
Verschwendung von Steuermitteln wenn man
ehrlich ist sie ist aus der Zeit
gefallen insgesamt kann man sagen dass
etwa zwei Drittel der Agrardiesel
Beihilfe an größere Haupterwerbsbetriebe
und juristische Personen fließen das
sind zugleich die Unternehmen die in den
letzten Jahren sehr gut verdient haben
er gehört zu denen die besonders viel
dieselsubventionen bekommen Joachim
ruckqut ist Großbauer und Präsident des
mächtigen Bauernverbandes rquet macht
den Agrardiesel zum Kern des Protests es
hinge davon die Existenz der Bauern ab
es wird ab nächster Woche wieder
Aktionen geben eher
nadelstichartig um noch mal auf
besondere Weise zum Ausdruck zu bringen
wie wichtig die Rücknahme ist doch die
Probleme gerade der kleinen und
mittleren Betriebe liegen weniger am
Diesel als an einer Politik die ruckwiet
und der Bauernverband seit Jahren mit
Stützen wer viel landwirtschaftliche
Fläche bewirtschaftet bekommt auch mehr
ab vom subventionskuchen der EU von den
gut 6 Milliarden Euro die jedes Jahr in
deutsche Bauern fließen die Folge
kleinere Betriebe geben auf die großen
dagegen bewirtschaften immer noch
größere Flächen wachse oder weiche seit
langem das Credo in der Landwirtschaft
mitgetragen über 16 Jahre von
unionslandwirtschaftsministern eine
nutzt die Proteste gleich selbst Bühne
Landwirtschaft Brau Planungssicherheit
und vor allen Dingen Verlässlichkeit und
Fairness eine Interviewanfrage von
Berlin direkt hingegen verweist Klöckner
lieber an einen Kollegen was hilft uns
jetzt diese
vergangenheitsbetrachtung also klar ist
auch in unserer Zeit nicht alles gut
gelaufen wir hatten auch immer
schwierige Umstände viel kommt von der
Europäischen Union man muss sich immer
mit dem Koalitionspartner verständigen
schuld sind meist die anderen dabei
kennen im Parlament offenbar alle die
Lösung bauernpems die
bekommissionkmission diekmission eben
diese becherkommission hat Vorschläge
gemacht für mehr Tierwohl nachhaltigere
bauenhilfen als den Agrardiesel doch
wieder Jim östemier noch zuvor Julia
Klöckner haben sie
umgesetzt das war schon frustrierend
denn alle haben die Vorschläge gelobt
und haben dann aber nicht die Kraft
gehabt die Umsetzung in Gang zu bringen
und wir hatten dann ja im letzten Jahr
waren wir seit dass gesagt hab es gibt
in dieser Legislaturperiode keine Chance
mehr und haben dann ja die Arbeit in der
Kommission eingestellt die ganze
Ratlosigkeit der Ampel zeigt ihr
Entschließungsantrag der eigentlich den
bauernprotest befrieden soll sieben
Fragen sind da formuliert Fragen die
sich seit Jahren stellen und auf die
jene die hier unterzeichnen wieder keine
Antworten
geben über die Grünen und die
Landwirtschaft spreche ich nun live bei
uns im Studio mit Katharina dröge der
Fraktions Vorsitzenden der Grünen im
Bundestag guten Abend Frau dröger wir
haben es ja gerade gesehen die Ampel
kann sich vor allen Dingen auf Fragen
zur Landwirtschaft einigen wie wollen
sie damit den Protest der Bauern von der
Straße bekommen also auf der einen Seite
haben wir mit den unterschiedlichen
Bauernverbänden als Fraktionsvorsitzende
auch über das gesprochen wo wir handeln
wollen und das haben wir jetzt erstmal
im Rahmen von einer handlungsagenda ganz
kurzfristig in derselben Woche in den
Bundestag eingebracht aber wir haben den
Bauern zugesagt dass in den wenigen
Monaten auch an all diesen Stellen dann
konkrete Gesetzesvorhaben und Reformen
stehen werden und das ist das woran wir
jetzt arbeiten die unterschiedlichen
Punkte sind in diesem auf
Handlungskonzept aufgeschrieben also
beispielsweise das Thema große
Marktmacht von Supermärkten die dazu
führen dass die Bauern von dem nicht
leben können was sie Herstell da müssen
sie an Kartellrecht dranghen oder
zumindest das kartellrechtlich prüfen
lassen an das Wettbewerbsrecht das wird
alles sehr lange dauern und die Bauer
haben wir schon gesagt morgen geht's
weiter wie also wollen sie das befrieden
jetzt kurzfristig also auf der einen
Seite haben wir den Bäuerinnen und
Bauern ja ein Kompromissangebot gemacht
das Ihnen jetzt erstmal nicht reicht das
ist absolut legitim aber da haben wir
als Ampel auch schon gezeigt wir haben
gesehen dass die Maßnahmen erstmal zu
viel waren für zu wenige und deswegen
bleibt die Steuervergünstigung bei der
kfzsteuer und der Agrardiesel wird nur
schrittweise abgeschmolzen nicht
befriedet aber in einer Demokratie
gehört ein Kompromiss auch dazu und von
diesem 60 Milliarden Paket sind so viele
unterschiedliche gesellschaftliche
Gruppen betroffen dass ich natürlich als
Fraktionsvorsitzender auch darauf
schauen muss die Belastung auf alle
Schultern gleichmäßig gerecht zu
verteilen trotzdem sehe ich die
herausfordernde Situation der bäuerinen
Bauern viele junge Landwirte fragen sich
ja habe ich noch eine Zukunft und
deswegen wollen wir die großen Fragen
jetzt gemeinsam angehen die dann
tatsächlich viel mehr über die Zukunft
entscheiden als dass der Agrardiesel tun
wird Jim östemier hat ja in den letzten
Tagen einen Kurs hingelegt den man
freundlich als ziigzack kururz
bezeichnen könnte er stand erst
natürlich Regierungsmitglied dann stand
er auf der Tribüne der Bauern dann ist
der wieder zur Regierung ähm gegangen um
deren Position zu unterstützen jetzt
versucht er so ein Mittelkurs wie
glauben Sie werden die Bauern darauf
reagieren warum sollten die ihm in der
nächsten Runde jetzt vertrauen also Jam
östtimir hat auf der einen Seite immer
sehr klar für die Anliegen der bäerinnen
und Bauern in dieser Bundesregierung
gekämpft das hat er auch direkt nachdem
die Entscheidung für das große Sparpaket
bekannt wurde und das ist jetzt auch das
was er in Zukunft den Landwirten
verspricht beispielsweise wenn er sagt
wenn ihr eure Stelle so umbaut dass die
Tierhaltung dort artgerechter ist dann
braucht ihr mehr finanzielle
Unterstützung und eine der Vorschläge
ist ja beispielsweise ein tierwohlzent
um das Ganze dann auch stärker als
bisher noch finanzieren zu können aber
den Bau reicht das ja nicht also sonst
das hat er ihnen angeboten aber es
reicht ihnen ja nicht sie müssen ja
jetzt irgendwie sehen dass diese
Traktoren von der Straße g kommomen oder
nicht also es gibt unterschiedliche
landwirtschaftliche Verbände und wir
hatten sie als Fraktionsvorsitzende alle
zum Gespräch eingeladen und in dieser
Vielfalt wurde auch deutlich dass es
durchaus unterschiedliche Perspektiven
gibt die milchvel beispielsweise hatten
als wichtigstes Anliegen die
vertragskondition mit den Molkereien die
die ökologische Landwirtschaft hat auf
die Herausforderung der Klimakrise für
die bauerinnen und Bauern und auf den
tierwohzend hingewiesen andere haben das
Thema marktmach der Supermärkte
angesprochen der Bauernverband den
Diesel und deswegen haben wir gesagt wir
wollen diesen Dialog fortsetzen damit
alle an einem Tisch dann jetzt auch
gemeinsam zu guten Lösung kommen im
Interesse der Bauern wä natürlich dass
sie das mit den Liberalen abgestemmt
haben da möchte ich zu meinem nächsten
Thema kommen aus den Kreisen der Ampel
war in den letzten Tagen immer wieder zu
hören dass sie jetzt die großen
strittigen Themen abgeräumt haben und
das nun Harmonie einkehren wird nun
fängt der Finanzminister an sich mit SPD
und Grünen über den Kinderfreibetrag zu
streiten erwarten sie da in den nächsten
Tagen eine Lösung also aus meiner Sicht
haben wir in der Ampel sehr klar
verabredet dass Kinderfreibetrag und
Kindergeld in gleichem Maße steigen
sollen dass man nicht das eine anheben
kann ohne das andere zu lassen das wäre
nicht gerecht denn den Kinderfreibetrag
kriegen sehr reiche Eltern für ihre
Kinder das Kindergeld kriegt die Mitte
der Gesellschaft und warum sollte ich
jetzt ausgerechnet die Kinder von sehr
reichen Menschen besser unterstützen als
die der Polizistinnen und Krankenpfleger
Herr Lindner sagt aber der Vorstoß von
ihm sei mit dem Kanzler abgestimmt also
aus meiner Sicht wird genau hierüber in
der Bundesregierung weiter gesprochen
und die SPD hat sich ja jetzt auch in
Form des Parteivorsitzenden hierzu
geäußert und meine Wahrnehmung bestätigt
sagt Katarina dröge die
Fraktionsvorsitzende der Grünen
herzlichen Dank für das Gespräch Frau
dröge ich danke Ihnen